Welcome back everyone it's Charlie there was a
new Marvel darkhold Diaries teaser that Aubry
Plaza just flat out dropped the other day so I'll
explain what's going on what is the teaser for and
what's going on with the darkhold during this
series that they're filming there were also a
couple of new scenes that dropped that teased the
return of Billy the adult version of Billy Scarlet
Witch's son if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos of course
we'll do episodes for it when it releases and
I'll explain how this is all connected because
they're all getting pretty meta with the series
the actual series is for Agatha coven of chaos
the reason why she is taking a picture of this
Banner is because it's for one of the episodes
that they're filming like the earlier Banner
that they posted a picture of saying Agatha
of Westview which was meant to be a parody of
Mayor of East Town so the pairing different
types of genres and different types of movies
with different episodes the same way they kind
of did that during one division where they started
to break the fourth wall and make you think that
you weren't inside other shows like shows within
shows within shows in the Darkhold Diaries font is
made to be a parody of The Princess Diaries like
it's the exact same font and during that episode
they'll just clown a little bit more on The
Princess Diaries the vibe is sort of like Agatha
all along but during wand division like the show
was Juan division it was all about Scarlet Witch
but for a brief moment they sort of broke the
fourth wall had a funny moment with Agatha all
along where she pretended like it was her show
the entire time the other super meta joke here
about the mayor of East Town reference to Agatha
of Westview is that obviously Ralph boner version
of quicksilver inside the MCU bit of a Magic
based spell version of quicksilver with Evan
Peters coming back playing a joke on his original
version of quicksilver but he was also a big
character during that mayor of East Town series
the actual show is after the coven of chaos but
it sounds like they're going to be doing this
with different episodes maybe not every single
episode but a lot of the episodes the fact that
this episode title is the Darkhold Diaries just
implies that a lot of it will get into the history
in the lore behind the Darkhold in the MCU they've
actually told a little bit of this during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Badness and wand division
devoted to
Damned during the comics the Darkhold was created
by cathode the god of chaos who's the person who
gave Scarlet Witch her chaos magic when she was
born he was part of a group called The Elder gods
that was banished from Earth's Dimension many
many years ago in ancient times and he used the
darkhold away to try and gain access to it again
his whole thing across history up into the modern
era of comics was trying to use Waze to get back
into Earth's dimensions that he could take over
again one of the other ways was to give Scarlet
Witch her chaos magic and use her as a sort of
fulcrum a back door to get back into Earth's
Dimension the way they explained the darkhold
in the MCU after Doctor Strange Multiverse
badass is it the darkhold Temple was created
by cathode in ancient times and it was like the
one source for all the different darkhold books
across the Multiverse all the Darkhold's were
copied from the inscriptions all over the walls
of the Darkhold Temple a few months ago a first
demon to Thorn carved his dark magic into this
tomb his same spells were later transcribed into
the Darkhold Scarlet Witch was meant to be the
one Scarlet Witch amongst the entire Multiverse
so like there are many wandas that have access
to chaos magic but only one of them would Ascend
to become the Scarlet which is the most powerful
version across the Multiverse they kind of teased
this during Doctor Strange Multiverse of Mattis
is that cathode had intended for Scarlet Witch to
use a being like America Chavez to gain access to
the Multiverse to take over the entire Multiverse
using the Darkhold Temple then after which c'thon
would take control of Scarlet Witch's mind and
he would gain control of the Multiverse to make
another one division Act of the Harkness joke it
was Agatha all along except in this case it was
cathode all along the way they're explained the
plot of the act of the coven of chaos series is
that it's the Salem 7 versus Agatha who's trying
to protect Joe Locke's character who's supposed
to be the adult version of Billy that's been
reincarnated in the Salem seven are trying to get
revenge on Agatha the Harkness for everything that
she did against them across history and gained
control of all magic because Billy is destined to
become the demiurge which is sort of like this God
like being that controls all magic making him just
as powerful if not more powerful than his mother
the Scarlet Witch Elizabeth Olsen is opposed
to Cameo during the series but they didn't say
how she's going to do that because obviously she
didn't die at the end of Doctor Strange Multiverse
of Badness like this where there's a red flash
if you don't see the body it's a comic book movie
that means she's still alive I don't think she's
supposed to physically come back like fully come
back until Avengers 5 King Dynasty so the way
they include her in Agatha the coven of chaos it
might be in flashbacks just referencing things
that happened in the past how Agatha escaped
her prison The Returned adult version of Billy's
relationship with Scarlet Witch and of course the
title here the Darkhold Diaries is just telling
you what Agatha did with the darkhold across all
those centuries because the Darkhold did rest with
her for a long time we got a couple flashbacks for
Agatha's origin story but it sounds like at some
point after that after she killed her own mother
her own coven then gained control of the darkhold
she went around going after other covens of wishes
which includes this one the Aubrey Plaza belongs
to that are going after her again for Revenge but
during this series Act of the Harkness is the main
character she's the protagonist they're playing
her like more of a straight up anti-hero trying to
help Billy Kaplan protect him from Morgan lafaye
and find out why they want him her Rogue coven of
witches in the larger machinations of Mephisto at
Play Because reportedly he's going to play a role
during the series like they'll actually finally
pay off some of these Mephisto jokes if you didn't
see the last couple of years reportedly Sasha
Baron Cohn has been filming different scenes as
a version of MCU Mephisto for different upcoming
series the brand new scenes we gotta look at are
of them filming at the West View mall you can see
them here with Billy Kaplan who's going to be the
Billy Kaplan Persona at least at the beginning of
the series before we learn what's really going
on with the character Billy Kaplan is really
technically quote unquote Billy maximoff played
by Joe lockheer he's the one that was posting
a lot of these clips these pictures so many
thanks to him if you zoom in enhancing this
one scene of them walking through the mall here
you can see the QR code in the background with a
message that says be an Insider that's been to
be another one of their huge Easter eggs with
the QR codes they've been doing in all the series
they did it in all the She-Hulk episodes they've
done it in a bunch of the other Marvel Disney
plus Series where you scan the QR code and you
can get free comics let me know in the comments
which free comics you think they're giving away
with these QR codes in the Agatha episodes maybe
some Agatha Harkness specific Comics maybe some
Young Avengers Billy Kaplan specific Comics you
see Agatha at the regular West View mall with
him eating snacks talking as if it's a normal day
in the neighborhood she's dressed in contemporary
casual clothing it doesn't look too goth down
which means she might still be in full-blown Agnes
mode when this happens under Scarlet Witch's spell
in this different scene there's a West View police
car which seems like it's part of the larger
mystery that Agatha uncovers as she's slowly
remembering what Scarlet wish did to her with
the spell in uncovering the plot to steal Billy
but the main idea during the series of the main
part of the story is Agatha trying to keep Aubry
Plaza's character Morgan lafay in her Covenant
witches away from Billy played by Joe lockheer
Morgan lafaye Rogue Covenant supposedly is the
one that's connected to Mephisto and the whole
idea at the end of West you like the big teaser
here when Agatha told Scarlet Witch you're going
to need me for what's coming you have no idea what
you've done you have no idea what you've unleashed
you're gonna need me if I do I know where to find
you wait that was tied more to what's happening
with the Multiverse Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty the
collapse of the Multiverse all these incursions
that they started teasing during Marvel phase four
like during Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
with other larger magical beings like Mephisto
taking advantage of the chaos like right now I
think the idea is that Mephisto is still trapped
in his own Dimension and seeking a way into the
main MCU Dimension they teased that a little
bit during Doctor Strange Multiverse about us
when they were traveling through the Multiverse
they traveled through one of the hell Dimensions
where pretty much the entirety of New York like
this entire reality had turned into a version of
hell like everything is on Fire part of the idea
is that Mephisto wants to take over the main MCU
Dimension like all the other higher beings across
the Marvel Multiverse and it sounds like based on
the plot he's trying to use Morgan lafaye's coven
whether they know it or not to take Billy for
himself use his power to take over the main MCU
Dimension because if it wasn't clear from all the
One Division episodes Billy has basically the same
types of powers of Scarlet Witch like he can warp
reality he's meant to be in incredibly powerful
magic user and just like in the Young Avengers
Comics Billy is destined to become the next
demiers this omnipotent magical being basically
like on the level of what you would expect Scarlet
Witch's powers to be like this Multiverse level of
power that could theoretically Change Control the
entire universe it sounds like if they're actually
using Mephisto as part of this series that's why
he really wants pillow like that's the real reason
in the same reason why Morgan lafaye's coven
would want him too like they would want him for
his power it just sounds like if they are using
Mephisto he's actually playing everyone like he's
lending them some power but also really trying to
play them during the series they also will address
what happened to Scarlet Witch like there's this
big rumor going around the magic community in
the MCU the Scarlet Witch has died and they'll
start to explore that and at some point during
the series we will see the new origin of Billy and
Tommy being reincarnated into the bodies of Billy
Kaplan and Tommy Shepard like we saw in the comics
it sounds like they'll be doing more Scarlet Witch
crossovers with the X-Men in Marvel phase 7
and beyond that was one of the things Elizabeth
said that she wanted to do that they had not
been able to do yet like she wanted to do more
X-Men crossovers in a lot of Marvel phase 7
and Beyond will be like really hardcore X-Men
stuff also sounds like a whole bunch of Young
Avengers stuff too let me know in the comments
though what else do you want them to do during
Agatha coven of chaos like obviously Agatha is
going to continue to be a big character in
Marvel going forward but essentially it's
kind of like a sequel to WAND division most
of the characters like the normal townspeople
that starred in one division will be coming back
during Agatha the coven of chaos it's just like
normal townspeople in Westview and it sounds
like at least the first couple of episodes or
maybe just the first episode will tease the
same thing that happened at the beginning of
One Division where like Agatha slowly wakes
up to the reality of what's actually going
on like wait a minute why is everything so weird
oh wait a minute that's right because I'm Agatha
Harkness and I'm super powerful and we'll see
her slowly Breaking Free of Scarlet Witch's
enchantment while she uncovers this larger
mystery with Morgan lafay in what's happening
with Billy Kaplan because they're filming we'll
be getting a whole bunch more footage real soon
so of course they'll do more videos as we get
more scenes if you have any any big questions
about what's going on during the series or like
other big Marvel Phase 5 Marvel phase six stuff
just write it below in the comments the next big
Marvel series is going to be secret invasion of
course I'll be doing episode videos for that just
like all the other big Marvel Disney plus series
make sure you enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that everyone click here for my brand
new Deadpool 3 video with Wolverine and click
here for my brand new Captain America 4 First
Look video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!